الدفاع الروسيه تتهم واشنطن بالتخطيط
لاستخدام مواد سامه في اوكرانيا
اسرائيل تحشد كتيبه عسكريه رابعه بحثا عن
منفذ عمليتي اريحا والحواره
الحكومه الكنديه تحضر تيك توك والبيت
الابيض يمهل الهيئات 30 يوما لحضرتك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اتهمه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
واشنطن بالتخطيط الاستفزازات في اوكرانيا
باستخدام اسلحه كيميائيه سامه قائد قوات
الحمايه الاشعاعيه والكيميائيه
والبيولوجيه في الجيش الروسي ايغور كيري
لوف ان قوته رصد التقدم عربات مدرعه
تحوي مواد كيميائيه نحو خطوط التماس في
اوكرانيا استعدادا للقيام باعمال
استفزازيه وكانت الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت امس
تدمير مركز الاستخبارات الالكترونيه
التابعه للجيش الاوكراني في منطقتك
في الاثناء اكد رئيس الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه كيريلو بودانوف انه لا يرى اي
مؤشر على ان الصين تعتزم امداد روسيا
باسلحه وقال في تصريحات لوسائل الاعلام
امريكيه انه لا يشاطر تقييمات مدير وكاله
الاستخبارات الامريكيه ويليامبرز بان
بيكين تدرس تزويد روسيا باسلحه فتاكه وهو
ما نفته الصين بشده واضاف بودانوف ان
اكياف تحتاج لامدادات اسلحه ضخمه وخاصه
الطائرات لتغيير مسار الحرب مشيرا الى ان
الاشهر الثلاثه المقبله حاسمه
قبل ذلك اعلن الكريم ان روسيا تاخذ خطط
السلام الصينيه على محمل التقدير وان هناك
بنودا مهمه في الخطه تتوافق مع توجهات
موسكو وشدد الكرملين على ان العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه داخل اوكرانيا نتج عنها
قضايا ساخنه تاخذها موسكو بعين الاعتبار
وفي هذا الصدد اعدل المتحدث باسم الكرب
ان الوضع الراهن لا يتيح فرصه لمناقشه
التسويه في اوكرانيا وان العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه ستستمر في اوكرانيا حتى تحقيق
كافه اهدافها الكريم اشار الى ان
استخبارات الغرب تعمل ضد موسكو على مدار
الساعه مضيفا ان امريكا وفرنسا وبريطانيا
تقف ايضا ضد روسيا من خلال تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمعدات العسكريه
ميدانيا انقلع قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه الكسندر سيسكي ان الوضع في
محيط مدينه بخموت اصبح متوترا للغايه وفي
رساله على تيليجرام اوضح الجنرال
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه دفعت بوحدات
هجوميات تابعه لمجموعات فاجنر العسكريه في
محاوله لاختراق دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني
بهدف فرض حصار على المدينه
وقال الرئيس الاوكراني فولادي ميرسي ان
بلاده بحاجه الى طائرات حربيه حديثه وانها
لا تستطيع الدفاع عن اجوائها الا اذا تم
رفع حظر الطيران بشكل كامل
بسبب الضربات الروسيه المتواصله نحتاج الى
طائرات حربيه حديثه لحمايه كامل لاراضي
دولتنا من الارهاب الروسي يكتمل الدفاع
الجوي عندما يكون لدينا طائرات حديثه
طيارون والوحدات المضاده للطائرات وغيرهم
خبراء سلاح الجو يقومون بعمل رائع سنكون
قادرين على حمايه اجوائنا عندما يتم رفع
حظر الطيران بالكامل
على صعيد العقوبات اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
اليابانيه عن تجميد اصول 39 شخصا وثلاثه
وسبعين منظمه من روسيا كما فرضت عقوبات
بشكل خاص على نائب وزير الدفاع الروسي
فيكتور غوريميكينا وكبار المسؤولين في
الاداره الرئاسيه الروسيه الخارجيه
اليابانيه اشارت ايضا الى ان طوكيو تعمل
على تجميل اصول تسع اشخاص اضافيين من
ادارات مقاطعات خرسون ولوجان سكوادونيات
اعلنت المتحدثات الرسميه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه عن استعداد موسكو
لاجراءات انتقاميه ردا على العقوبات
الامريكيه والكنديه زخرفه وصفت الاجراءات
التي ستتخذها بلادها ضد واشنطن
وبالاجراءات ذات التاثير المركز مشيره الى
ان العقوبات الروسيه ستنطلق من مبادئ
المعامله بالمثل الصارمه وحتميه العقاب
على حد وصفه
رحب البيت الابيض على لسان المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كاربي رحب
بزياره وزير خارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان لاوكرانيا ونتائجها وفي رد على
السؤال للعربيه قال جونكر بان السعوديه
تقوم بخطوات كبيره لدعم استقرار المنطقه
وان الدعم السعودي للشعب الاوكراني خطوه
مهمه
السعوديه تعتبر شركه استراتيجيا للولايات
المتحده منذ ثمانيه عقود ونحن نرحب بزياره
وزير خارجيه السعوديه لاوكرانيا ونتائجها
خصوصا ان اعلان مساعدات بقيمه 400 مليون
دولار ستساعد اوكرانيا كثيرا كما ان الدعم
السعودي للشعب الاوكراني يشكل خطوه مهمه
اضافه الى ذلك فان السعوديه تقوم بخطوات
كبيره لدعم استقرار المنطقه
في جوله لها على الحدود البولنديه
الاوكرانيه
عربيه استمرار تدفق اللاجئين الاوكرانيين
الذين لم يتوقف عبورهم المنطقه الحدوديه
نحو بولندا وان كانت اعدادهم قد تراجعت
نسبيه
لا تتوقفوا قوافل نقل المساعدات العسكريه
الى اوكرانيا ولا ينقطع التدفق مساعدات
انسانيه عبر شاحنات تنتظر طويلا عند
الحدود وصلنا الى اقصى جنوب شرق بولندا
هنا تقع حدود اوكرانيا مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومع حلف النيتو وهو ما يفسر خشيه
البولنديين الدائمه من ان يصبحوا يوما خط
التماس الاول في المواجهه بين موسكو
والغرب الغرب دخل في تصعيد كلامي حاد ضد
روسيا حتى ان فرنسا اولت داعين الى الحوار
سابقا باتت تتحدث عن مواصله دعم اوكرانيا
حتى النصر اليوم
امر
الوقت الحاضر ومسانده بكل الوسائل الممكنه
ليوكرانيا حتى تدافع عن
نفسي نفسها نحن
اليوم مع اوكرانيا بكل وسايلنا هذا النصره
استرجاع اوكرانيا اراضيها المحتله
استرجاع سيادتها وسلامتها قبل عام دخل عبر
هذه الحدود الى بولندا حوالي تسعه ملايين
لاجئ اوكرانيا توزع معظمهم لاحقا على دول
اوروبيه مجاوره اليوم تراجعت اعداد
الهاربين من الحرب لكنها لم تتوقف بعد عام
على بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا ما زالت محطه
قطارات بشميشل هنا عند الجانب البولندي من
الحدود بين البلدين نقطه استراحه عابره
للاجئين الاوكرانيين قبل انطلاقهم نحو
وجهه جديده المئات منهم ينتظرون هنا منذ
ساعات بعد ان قدموا من مدينه ازابوريجيا
جنوب شرق اوكرانيا وهم ينتظرون هنا القطار
الذي
سيستقلونه للوصول اولا الى العاصمه
البولنديه ومن هناك يتجه ون نحو مدينه
هانوفر الالمانيه صور اللاجئين هنا تعكس
استمرار محنه الاوكرانيين وحاجاتهم الماسه
الى الاغاثه الدوليه
[موسيقى]
نقدم للاجئين دعما بالمعلومات ونساعدهم
للحصول على كل ما يحتاجون اليه من ايجاد
ماوى ووسيله نقل ونجيب على كل اسئلتهم الى
هذه المحطه الواقعه عند الحدود البولنديه
يصل يوميا من اوكرانيا حوالى
من عشرات الالاف يوميا قبل عام حسين قنيبر
العربيه من منطقه الحدود البولنديه
الاوكرانيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي في خبر عاجل يدعو الى
سرعه وقف التصعيد وانهاء العنف الضفه
الغربيه حيث شهدت العديد من البلدات في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه مواجهات عنيفه مع
القوات الاسرائيليه تحديدا في جنوب نابلس
وجنوب جنين وبعض بلدات القدس ورام الله
وبحسب وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه اعتدى
مستوطنون على سياره اسعاف اثناء مرورها من
زعتره بجنين حيث كانت تنقل طفله مريضه الى
قسم العنايه المكثفه بمستشفى في رام الله
وقد اصيبت والده الطفله بجروح جراء
التكسير المستوطنين لزجاج الاسعاف هذا
وشهدت نابلس اعمال عنف ترى وحت بين مهاجمه
مركبات الفلسطينيين وحدوث مواجهات في
حواره جنوب نابلس الى حرق وتدمير عشرات
المنازل
[موسيقى]
وعلقت جامعه النجاح الوطنيه ومديريه
التربيه والتعليم في جنوب نابلس دوام
الطلبه اليوم غدا واعلن التحول الى
التعليم عن بعد بسبب اعتداءات مستوطنين
المتواصله ياتي هذا القرار تزامنا مع دفع
اسرائيل المزيد من التعزيزات العسكريه
لضفه الغربيه المحتله عبر فرض طوق امنيا
على المدينه وحشد كتيبه عسكريه رابعه في
محاوله لتعزيز عمليه مطارده منفذ عمليتي
اريحا وحواره في ظل تصاعدي حده اعتداءات
المستوطنين في الضفه
اعتبر جون كاربي المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي في رد على سؤال للعربيه
ان موقف واشنطن من المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
ثابت ويعتبر ان توسيع المستوطنات عقبه في
طريق السلام كرر اضاف ان العنف الذي حدث
في نابلس من حرق لمنازل الفلسطينيين من
قبل المستوطنين ومجرد مثال اخر على اهميه
جمع الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي معا
للعمل على طرق للتخفيف من حده التصعيد
موقفنا من المستوطنات ثابت ولم يتغير حيث
نعتبر توسيع المستوطنات عقبه في طريق
السلام والعنف الذي رايناه مؤخرا في نابلس
هو مجرد مثال اخر على اهميه ان نجمع
الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي معا للعمل
على تخفيف حده التصعيد وبرغم ما حدث لا
يزال هناك مؤشرات جيده على الاقل حول
استعداد الطرفين لخفض التصعيد وهو ما
رايناه من بيانات الجانب الاسرائيلي التي
تدين ما فعله المستوطنون
نشره مستمره وفيها بعض الفصل
البرلمان الليبي يرحب بمبادره امميه
لاجراء انتخابات تجمع
جميع الابطال
اهلا بكم من جديد قدر البنك الدولي خسائر
تركيا الماديه المباشره جراء الزلزلين
الكبيرين في السادس من فبراير بنحو 34
مليار و200 مليون دولار ورجح ان تكون
اجمالي تكاليف اعاده الاعمار والتعافي
التي تواجهها البلاد قد يكون ضعفي ذلك
34 مليارا و200 مليون دولار قيمه اضرار
الزلزلين في تركيا
تكاليف اعاده الاعمار والتعافي في تركيا
بعد زلزاليل السادس من فبراير قد يكون
ضعفي ذلك
بحسب تقديرات البنك الدولي سيخفض
الزلزالان ايضا ما لا يقل عن نصف نقطه
مئويه من نمو الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
المتوقع لتركيا هذا العام بين 3.5 واربعه
هذا ما قاله مدير مكتب البنك الدولي في
تركيا
هامبيرتولوبز قال البنك الدولي ان 7500 هز
ارتداديه اعقبت الزلزالين مما تسبب في
اكبر كارثه من هذا النوع تشالها تركيا منذ
اكثر من 80 عاما تقرير البنك الدولي يشير
الى ان مليون و250 الف شخص اصبحوا بلا
ماوى بسبب الاضرار التي لحقت بمنازلهم او
انهيارها بشكل كامل
البيت الدولي قدم مساعده فوريه قيمتها 780
مليون دولار لتركيا بالاضافه الى مليار
دولار في مشروع تعاف طارئ جديد
طلاب جامعه طهران وخرجوا في مظاهرات ضد
قرار التعليم عن بعد
[تصفيق]
اعلنت محكمه موريال انها حكمت بالسجن لمده
تسع سنوات على الايرانيين نادر جيرمان
بتهمه غسل الاموال والتحويل غير القانونيه
من والى ايران والصين ولبنان وفرضت غرامه
قدرها 920 الف دولار ومصادره ممتلكاته
التي قدرت بنحو خمسه ملايين دولار
غادر عدد من المشاركين في اجتماع الامم
المتحده لحقوق الانسان في جناف الجلسه
خلال حديث وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد اللهيان كلمته
[موسيقى]
حضرت الحكومه الكنديه التطبيق تيك توك على
كل هواتفها واجهزتها مشيره الى مخاوف على
صعيد حمايه البيانات وجاء في بيان للحكومه
انه اعتبارا من اليوم الثلاثاء سيتم حذف
تطبيق تيك توك عن الاجهزه المحموله التي
تمنحها الحكومه كما سيتم منع مستخدمي هذه
الاجهزه من تنزيل التطبيق في المستقبل
كما امهل البيت الابيض الهيئه الحكوميه 30
يوم للتاكد من عدم وجود تطبيق تيك توك على
اي من الاجهزه او الانظمه التابعه للحكومه
الاتحاديه وقالت مديره مكتب الاداره
والميزانيه
للجهات الحكوميه في مذكره توجيهيه انه
سيكون مطلوبا منها تعديل عقود تكنولوجيا
المعلومات للتاكد من ان المتعاقدين يحمون
بيانات الولايات المتحده من خلال وقف
استخدام تيك توك على الاجهزه والانظمه
المستخدمه في اطار عملهم
رحب رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون عبر
صفحته الرسميه على موقع تويتر بالاتفاق
بين المملكه المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
بشان تنفيذ اطار عمل ما بعد خروج بريطانيا
من الاتحاد الاوروبي في ايرلندا الشماليه
ماكرون وصف القرار بالمهم وقال انه يحمي
السوق الداخليه الاوروبيه
ما كان مستعصيا على اسلافه حققه رئيس
الحكومه البريطانيه اذ توصل الى اتفاق مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي لحل مشاكل البروتوكول
ايرلندا الشماليه الذي يخضع هذا الاقليم
التابعه للتاج البريطاني بعد لقوانين
السوق الاوروبيه الموحده للحفاظ على حدود
مفتوحه بين ايرلندا الشماليه وجارتها
الجنوبيه العضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي كما
يفرض اجراءات التفتيش جمركيه للبضائع من
انحاء بريطانيا الى هذه المقاطعه الشماليه
سوناك اشاد بهذا الاختراق الحاسم
عن يسعدني ان ابلغكم اننا حققنا تقدما
حاسما معا قمنا بتغيير البروتوكول الاصلي
ونعلن اليوم عن اطار عمل الدستور الجديد
توفر اتفاقيه اليوم تدفقا سلسا للتجاره
داخل المملكه المتحده باكملها وتحمي مكانه
ايرلندا الشماليه في اتحادنا وتحمي
السياده لشعب ايرلندا الشماليه
اطار عمل وينزر جاء نتيجه التوتر الذي
اثاره بروتوكول ارلوندا الشماليه بتعطيل
عمل السلطه التنفيذيه المحليه لاكثر من
سنه ناهيك عن بيروقراطيه نقل البضائع الى
المقاطعه الشماليه وستتيح هذه التسويه
الجديده توافر جميع المواد الغذائيه
والادويه البريطانيه في اسواق اراندا
الشماليه عبر مسارين واحد اخضر للبضائع
المتوجهه لايرلندا الشماليه واخر احمر
للبضائع الذي قد تتوجه للاتحاد الاوروبي
كما تعطي المجلس المحلي رايا في القوانين
الاوروبيه التي تحكمهم
لقد توصلنا الى اتفاق في اطار عمل يفرض
تسويه جديده فيما يخص ايرلندا وايرلندا
الشماليه اطار العمل سيكون بدايه لفصل
جديد بيننا ويؤمن حلولا طويله الامد والتي
ستناسب الجميع في ايرلندا الشماليه
يقول ان الاتفاق الجديد مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي بشان بروتوكول ايرلندا الشماليه
يصحح عيوب
والتحدي الذي يواجه ريشيسوناك الان هو
اقناع الاطراف السياسيه هنا في بريطانيا
لقبول هذه التسويه الجديده
على راس هؤلاء الحزب الوحدوي الديمقراطي
بالفصل الذي جمد صيغه تقاسم السلطه وفق
معاهده السلام بسبب البروتوكول الذي اثر
على التجاره بين بريطانيا وايروندا
الشماليه لابقاء هذه المقاطعه في السوق
الموحده كما سيكون على سوناك كسب اعضاء
حزبه وخاصه جناحه المتشدد في مجموعه
الابحاث الاوروبيه فيما ابدت المعارضه
تاييدها للاتفاق لازاله عقبات وتصحيح
اخطاء البروتوكول السابق مصطفى العربيه
لندن
مشاهدينا الخارجيه الصينيه تعلق على قرار
حظر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لتطبيق
تيك توك
وترفضه وتعتبر انه يقمع الشركات الاجنبيه
ويتجاوز مفهوم الامن القومي كندا ايضا
حضراته الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا فعلت نفس
الشيء نتابع حتى زعيم كوريا الشماليه
المسؤولين الحكوميين على ضروره اجراء
تغيير جذري في الانتاج الزراعي وفق ما
ذكرت وكاله الانباء المركزيه الكوريه واكد
زعيم كوريا الشماليه ان التغييرات يجب ان
تحدث في السنوات القليله المقبله قائلا ان
تحقيق اهداف انتاج الحبوب هذا العام
اولويه قصوى عبر ايجاد مهام فوريه واهداف
علميه طويله المدى من اجل ما اسماه تحولا
اساسيا للتنميه المستقره والمستدامه
للزراعه
نهايه النشره تذكرهم بالعناوله
الدفاع الروسيه تتهم واشنطن بالتخطيط
لاستخدام مواد سامه في اوكرانيا
اسرائيل تحشد كتيبه عسكريه رابعه بحثا عن
منفذ عمليتي اريحا وحواره
الحكومه الكنديه تحضر تيك توك والبيت
الابيض يمهل الهيئات 30 يوما لحظر التطبيق
اراكم على راس الساعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
نقطع بس انا لننتقل الى تركيا وتطورات
الزلزال ايش اللي صار وقت الزلزال اروي
لنا القصه سابدا
بالسؤال الصمت في هذا الموقع يحاول سماع
اصوات قادمه من تحت الركاب
عدد القتلى الجرحى المباني المهدمه فلا
يزال عشرات العائلات والاشخاص تحت الانقاض